ökologen ganze zeit über sich und
herzlich willkommen zu einem video aus
einem berliner hotel
ich nehme mir meinen schlimmsten scheint
youtube wie ich habe schon leben auf
twitter gefragt hey leute was kann man
für den challenge machen hotelzimmer
oder meinte hey du dummkopf mache bin
ich klar
deswegen machen will wo ich klebeband
hab ich glaube dass ihr wir haben das
klebeband und wir haben die defizite
geschrieben
wir werden nichts gegen seinen kopf
kleben ihr könnt das vielleicht noch
schließt die augen
ich hab den zettel an erzählte auch
bewacht beklebt ist macht halt in die
haare als ich hatte dadurch kraft
dadurch gucken die auch ganz durchkommen
war
nun macht er schon so ein dickes ding
[Musik]
hier wird auch so aussehen wie sie muss
auch nicht sehen vor kanzlerin knappen
rede an meine augen reiben 12 uhr mit
der woche wir nehmen das gerade
mitternacht auf die so oder jetzt kriege
ich meinen zettel auf den herd
[Musik]
wohin sollte er ein guter torwart
so leute dann würde ich sagen der peter
pan ganze frage also wenig weiblich bin
ich weiblich neue chance wahr machen mit
zwei argumenten fragen oder zwei sagt
man mal wieder runter gefahren für mich
über 500.000 habe ich vielleicht über
500.000 abonnenten ja okay bin ich ein
deutscher youtuber umgeworfen wird er
noch abend ich lade kein geld auf einem
kanal hochstimmung
damit bin ich mit der gang da ja oder
nein
ich find sagen nein ich meine nicht habe
ich habe nein das ist nicht schwarz
diesen schutz überrollt bin ich
joyce in kalkutta der gewiss kein geld
hast du ja ich hab's gefragt war steinen
ich wollte dich richtig dass ich das ich
bin weiblich
nein widmen sich etwas gefangen bin ich
weiß nicht ja okay dass ich bin männlich
auch irgendwann komme ich denn ich habe
nichts mit gaming wird er in frage
stellen
bekommst du wirst du hast gefragt bin
ich wenn ich männlich sagt nein ich
wollte die antworten ja ich bin ich hab
ich mir jetzt hunderttausenden schneide
ich meine videos sehr aufwendig nein ich
würde ich sagen okay ich mache musik auf
meinen teil bin ich allein auf meinen
kanal mache ich blogs unter anderem
würde ich sagen dieses jahr habe ich
lasse mich herum gespielt
nein
okay ich mache kein gaming awards kein
geld zitiert ich okay du bist dran bin
ich unter zwang ist schwierig um so um
die 20 will ich sagen ich weiß noch
nicht ob du weißt wie alt die person ist
ehrlich gesagt also ich kenne ihn nicht
doch du kennst du kennst dich werde den
tipp geben wir kommen auf jeden fall
drauf macht kein gaming unter 100000 ja
da wird der kopf leicht die youtuber ihm
zu 100.000 über eine million
du hast gefragt habe habe ich nicht voll
doch mehr 5000 ja ja also ich mach
irgendwas wie kommen die comedy und
irgendwas wie blogs und ja aber ich bin
größtenteils alleine klar habe ich
vielleicht nie vielleicht sogar zwei ich
bin ich mache ich
zufällig bin ich richtig was bin ich in
einem multi channel network gepachtet ja
aber die schon sagen ich weiß dass mit
sicherlich auch schon
du hast dich ich sagte ihr sohn ihr den
tipp du hast letztes eine aktion gegen
über diese person gemacht halt so da er
nicht so nicht so nicht so nicht diese
person
das heißt ich kann deutschland aktion
quasi rückgängig gemacht jetzt kommt
dieses du bist meisters allein war
falsch also aktion der behandlung eine
kleine alle handlungen kenne ich die
habe ich diese person persönlicher mal
getroffen ja gewusst weil diese person
bei dem video der 2015
ja er wird vielmehr die folge noch nicht
diese nicht
[Musik]
ich bin männlich
er ist jetzt ganz okay geben
ich habe die chance gegeben und ich habe
auch den vierten gewinne machen
weiterhin ein doch nein
und wie locker vier mal bin ich schon
du bist nicht juli endlich in deutsch
mache ich los auf meine ja also blogs
und so komme ich aus köln ich weiß gar
nicht doch sind die personen
was ist denn los mit dem was ich
ausschließlich bloß eine aktion gegen
die über dieser person gebracht
online aktion also rückgängig gemacht
dass letzten verhandlungen rückgängig
gemacht diese aktion kann man auch total
rückgängig machen denkt nach geld
nein
das scheint es länger her welcher so vor
allem machte gaming vest den meisten
geboten
[Gelächter]
wenn ich eigentlich bin okay sagte
zuerst nur jemand der unbedingt wollte
dass die mutter nicht mehr eltern
verwandte beschreibt man auch wenn ich
kinder tragen wir abbauen
du warst schon mit den weiblichen
kanälen so gesagt hat das war nah dran
das ist glaube ich ganz gut
der krasseste tipp die man jeden tag
nein ich weiß nicht welche weiblichen du
bist nicht mein offizieller oder
wirklich auch nicht gern wirklich nicht
geld ja angeblich
natürlich ist die waren oder so als ob
die nicht ewig jung
ich habe meine kommentare wie janko
geübt
das war das von den wieder von heute
wenn das gefallen hat dann halt alle
leute geht nach hause und trinken ich
habe mir die ami klar